Speaker 1: Protests have been boiling over in
China against COVID restrictions nearly three
years into the COVID 19 pandemic. In Shanghai and
in universities across the country, we're hearing
of demonstrations, people chanting things like
Step down, Xi Jinping, step down, Communist Party.
Also chants like, We don't want COVID tests, we
want freedom and we don't want dictatorship. We
want democracy. Police are arresting people
at these protests, trying to send a message
to people to stand down and stay home and their
videos of police dragging away protesters, beating
protesters. I won't subject you to them now. Also
recently, a deadly fire at an apartment block in
Xinjiang killed ten people and injured nine. And
what's being blamed for why so many people were
killed and hurt by this was the COVID lockdown
measures which reportedly delayed firefighters
from being able to reach the victims. So I'm sure
everyone knows that China has maybe the strictest
COVID restrictions. They have had those severe
restrictions this entire time. And unlike other
countries that took the virus very seriously, but
later eased up the restrictions as vaccines were
rolled out and as other treatments were rolled
out. China has just been strict this entire time,
easing up very little like we've seen these places
like New Zealand and Australia, for example,
that were strict on travel and these other things
during much of 2020 and 2021. But then eventually
their population was exposed to the virus once it
became more manageable. China, on the other hand,
has been sticking to COVID zero, a.k.a. dynamic
COVID, which includes everything from having
negative tests required for people who enter
a business or public place to government
supervised quarantines to lockdowns when cases are
detected in significant enough numbers. Even just
this year, there were, of course, lockdowns in
Shanghai, and there was also that shutdown that
took place a few weeks ago at Disney World. It
seems like just with all of these restrictions,
with how long it's been going on, people are
just reaching their boiling point. And certainly
policies like these can last a lot longer in a
place like China than they could in the United
States. I mean, here in the US, people threw a
fit because they had to wear masks in public for
longer than two weeks. It became more than just,
you know, two weeks to slow the spread. So people
went ballistic over in China. They've been
dealing with this stuff for a lot longer and
much more severe restrictions. People, I think,
just ultimately only have so much patience for
this. And the only the other problem that
Xi Jinping has right now is that he has to
ease up on restrictions to keep people happy
while at the same time not make it look like
the Chinese government is changing its mind
because that could lower their credibility in
terms of how they see it. Like I would view
this as like, okay, well, he's just looking
at how COVID has changed. It's not killing as
many people. We have the tools to deal with it,
so it makes sense that the government would switch
their position. But in China, the sort of idea is
that if he decides to back off of COVID zero, then
it would suggest that he was wrong to institute it
in the first place. And so they have to stick
with this zero tolerance approach to COVID,
even as it may end up looking like more
and more of a failure and not sustainable
anymore. So Xi Jinping is backed into a
corner. The entire country has to respond
by doing these protests. I've seen people
talk about how protests in China are common,
but long lasting protests and protests in so many
places throughout the country are much, much less
common. And we'll see if this is able to stand up
in terms of the numbers. China is recording about
3000 new COVID cases a day, which is a lot more
than they were admitting to, at least, you know,
earlier on in the pandemic. Like there was times
where there was a little surge at the beginning
of this year. But during much of the time when
the world was dealing with the most severe COVID
outbreaks, China wasn't having too much of a
problem with it, which is crazy to see because
they have a population of 1.4 billion people and
they would say, Oh, well, we only had 100 new
cases today or 200 new cases today. And people
either suspect that they were so strict with
their lockdowns and COVID measures that they were
able to achieve that. Other people say they were
clearly fudging the numbers, but regardless of
what they were doing before, now they're saying
3000 is the number that they're getting just about
every day. It's hard to predict where this story
is going to go next, especially because protests
so often in China are short lived. But at the same
time, this COVID zero policy seems unsustainable.
And it seems like COVID is not going to be
completely eradicated, at least not anytime soon.
And so the government of China will eventually
have to adapt and bring about some changes.
But the question is, will a bunch of people
be jailed and maybe killed before that happens,
or will there be some sort of sensible policy
change that comes to China in the near future?
I'm rooting, of course, for some sort of peaceful
ending to this all to still take the virus very
seriously, but to ease up on the restrictions,
because it seems like after three years, people
are just. Not willing to deal with it anymore.